bonjour Frédéric Van tout merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes le député de Salim vous êtes
député de Seine-et-Marne du groupe
horizon à l'Assemblée nationale et on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien Lecuyer
de la Voix du Nord bonjour Julien
bonjour Yann bonjour monsieur valtour on
va commencer par les retraites
ce matin à l'Agence France Presse que le
gouvernement va ouvrir une concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux et les
groupes parlementaires dès la semaine
prochaine sur la réforme des retraites
fin des consultations à Noël adoption ou
pas par le Parlement avant la fin de
l'hiver et entrer en vigueur elle était
en tout cas le calendrier soit Elisabeth
borne est-ce que ce sont un calendrier
une méthode qui vous convienne oui de la
discussion il y a d'abord eu la
discussion interne à la majorité
présidentielle jusqu'à ce rendez-vous
hier soir autour du président de la
République puis ensuite discussion avec
les partenaires sociaux étaient
différentes forces politiques
pendant encore besoin de discuter parce
que les partenaires sociaux ils ont
clairement fait connaître l'imposition
alors oui il y a toujours besoin de
discuter d'une part et d'autre part il y
a aussi besoin peut-être de pédagogie
vis-à-vis des Français c'est à dire que
trois mois ce sera pas inutile aussi
pour expliquer que au-delà des
partenaires sociaux il va falloir faire
expliquer la réforme aux Français
qu'est-ce qu'il faut expliquer parce que
en effet ils ont bien compris qu'ils
devraient travailler plus ça ils l'ont
bien ils l'ont bien saisi mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut leur expliquer en plus il
faut leur expliquer le contenu de la
réforme et que au-delà de ça c'est un
c'est un ensemble il y a des mesures
effectivement sur l'âge il y a des
mesures sur la pénibilité il y a un
équilibre global du système il y a a
priori d'après ce que j'ai compris mais
on connaît pas encore le texte et je
n'étais pas au dîner hier soir mais il y
a aussi la question des régimes spéciaux
qui doivent être posés donc c'est un
ensemble de réformes c'est pas juste une
mesure d'âge qu'on pose comme ça au
milieu de la table et on dit basta on
s'arrête là on a entendu parler de plus
d'efforts mais il faut plus de justice
ça doit passer par quoi
minimum à 1100 euros c'est la prise en
compte c'est de la dentelle c'est la
prise en compte des pas longue c'est la
prise en compte d'un certain nombre
effectivement de situations qui
voilà doivent être mieux appréciées et
qui d'après ce que je comprends là
encore serait pris en compte en tout cas
c'était le cas dans la réforme qui était
poussée par le gouvernement d'Édouard
Philippe en 2019 qui a été interrompu à
cause du covid donc est-ce qu'on repart
complètement de cette
Édouard
[Musique]
66 ou au-delà point il avait mais lancé
cette phrase en évoquant c'est c'est de
cette manière là le fait que ça devait
pas être un tabou l'âge de la retraite
et qu'aujourd'hui à un moment où on vit
tous un peu plus vieux on est tous en
forme à cet âge-là où on part tous de
toute façon à la retraite en moyenne
au-delà de 62 ans c'est 63 ans l'âge de
départ à la retraite
au-delà de l'âge légal donc on voit bien
toute façon tout ça bouge et mérite
d'être reposé mais François Bayrou il a
eu raison quand même de mettre la
pression sur le gouvernement pour
rappeler à plus de concertation
finalement l'effet lui donne un peu
raison
je sais pas si la manière dont il l'a
fait il a eu raison de de le faire
chacun son style Edouard Philippe et le
groupe Horizon a toujours dit qu'il
serait au rendez-vous en soutien du
gouvernement pour cette réforme et
François Béraud à son style on le
connaît ben écoutez posez-lui la
question alors une autre question que
par contre que je veux vous poser c'est
c'est la menace de dissolution qui a
porté Emmanuel Macron hier très
clairement il a dit si une motion de
censure qui est adoptée il
annoncera la dissolution voilà on
retournera à faire campagne de toute
façon c'est le jeu des institutions
c'est à dire qu'effectivement si le
gouvernement est tombe à la suite d'un
49-3 en fait d'une motion de censure
pardon qui serait adopté ça veut dire
que le Président de la République
n'envisage pas de trouver dans
l'assemblée actuelle de quoi organiser
un gouvernement stable pour la France
donc sans doute qu'effectivement il
pousse un raisonnement jusqu'au bout
cette notion de censure non soyez
certains députés à la France insoumise
qui se disent qu'ils sont faits
en ce moment chacun menace Marine Le Pen
disait qu'elle était prête à voter la
mention de censure de la nups on voit
bien que ce serait de toute façon
complètement aberrant et d'ailleurs je
pense que les Français le
fonctionneraient de de de ce jusqu'au
boutisme de vouloir défaire le
gouvernement de la France et et voir
l'extrême droite soutenir l'extrême
gauche je suis pas sûr que vraiment mis
au pied du mur ils iraient jusque là ou
en tout cas ça voudrait dire
qu'effectivement ici il préfère le
n'importe quoi à une stabilité des
institutions je vais pas vous rappeler
les les dernières réformes des des
retraites qui ont été engagés avec
toujours ses complications et toujours
des grèves massives dans le dans le pays
quasiment toujours et ce qu'il faut
d'ores et déjà se dire que cet hiver ça
va être encore une fois un hiver social
très chaud des fois qu'on est chaud chez
nous ça risque d'être très chaud dans la
rue écoutez je pense que le contexte est
quand même particulier contexte
international contexte sur le coût de la
vie et la pression effectivement sur le
coup de la vie l'énergie cher tout ça
dessine quand même un paysage compliqué
les syndicats vont aussi être appelés à
leur responsabilité c'est-à-dire de
prendre en compte ce contexte-là avant
effectivement de voir peut-être je sais
pas si c'est leur intention bloquer des
transports bloqués des institutions
voilà bloquées en tout cas le pays je
pense pas que aujourd'hui le sujet se
pose aussi simplement qu'il y a à
d'autres périodes où on n'était pas dans
ce contexte de tension extrême et de
difficultés annoncées voilà je pense que
ça sera à prendre en compte et les trois
mois vont être nécessaires pour
expliquer tout ça et sans doute aussi
pour que chacun puisse prendre ses
responsabilités moi je le souhaite et
justement on va parler de l'inflation
oui parce que Édouard Philippe a la
rentrée de d'horizon de votre partie
alerté contre les tentations qui
pourraient apporter apparaître chez
certains je le cite de considérer que la
variable d'ajustement l'endroit où on
pourrait diminuer plus facilement la
dépense publique ce sont les
collectivités territoriales alors
l'Association des maires de France le
rejoint dans cette dans cette inquiétude
vous étiez mère de Fontainebleau il y a
encore quelques quelques semaines est-ce
que vous ne craignez pas en effet que
les collectivités territoriales fassent
les frais des mesures d'économie pour
l'instant ça n'a pas été le cas et et
elles ont été accompagnées dans les
projets loi sur qui ont été discuter cet
été il y a eu des gros quand même que
Bruno Le Maire a mis un coup de pression
sur les collectivités territoriales
qu'on sont revenus une forme d'accord de
Cahors autour de la question toujours
cet équilibre entre la citadelle de
Bercy et ceux qui la tiennent et les
pouvoirs locaux quel que soit le
gouvernement et ça depuis 30 ans 40 ans
depuis que la décentrale est surexique
les moments ils sont pas bien sûr
[Musique]
ça fera partie des sujets qu'on
regardera de près effectivement il y a
déjà un principe effectivement
d'accompagnement de la du plus grand
nombre des des communes c'est les plus
les plus petites moins de 10 ans enfin
c'est quand même quasiment plus de 3
en 2023 de ce fait bon il faudra
d'ailleurs expliquer
aux habitants précisément ce que
signifie cette augmentation mécanique de
leur taxe foncière pour ceux qui
l'appelle mais c'est vrai que voilà il y
a tous ces paramètres à prendre en
compte on peut pas tout indexer sur sur
l'inflation on va parler du budget de la
Sécurité sociale parmi les mesures de ce
budget il y a une année supplémentaire
pour les internes en médecine générale
quatrième année que le gouvernement va
inciter à faire dans les déserts
médicaux c'est une bonne méthode pour
vous c'est une bonne mesure si c'est pas
la seule mesure c'est à dire c'est une
bonne mesure mais elle résoudra pas à
elle seule le sujet des désirs médicaux
c'est un ensemble de mesures qui doivent
être prises et effectivement qui doivent
permettre qu'on répartissent mieux les
forces enfin les professionnels de santé
sur l'ensemble du territoire qu'on
facilite l'accès des Français aux soins
alors il y a cette affaire effectivement
d'une quatrième année médecine mais
quelque part c'est un peu la logique les
étudiants médecine générale faisaient de
la médecine générale une spécialité et
se sont battus pendant des années pour
que ce soit reconnue comme une
spécialité qui sont sympas une sous un
sous cursus et bien ce qui est une
spécialité c'est 4 ans d'internat et
donc quelque part c'est l'alignement sur
ce quatrième année de des études de
médecine générale voilà après pour le
reste sans doute qu'il faudra peut-être
aller un petit peu plus loin pour
faciliter ou encourager allez les
médecins allez un petit peu plus loin
est-ce que c'est plus de contraintes
plus de contraintes ça peut être aussi
c'est parce qu'il y a la question des
gardes aussi du partage des gardes parce
que vous êtes très très offensif sur
cette question d'ailleurs les médecins
libéraux vous le reprochent suffisamment
ils aiment pas trop qu'on dise des
choses qu'ils n'ont pas envie d'entendre
mais c'est pourtant ils vont y venir et
ils y viennent malgré tout c'est à dire
que même comprennent que aujourd'hui ils
peuvent pas s'exonérer de toute
contrainte dans un système qui
effectivement dans lequel ils ont
participé parce que je rappelle que
c'est eux c'est pas moi qui négocie les
conventions médicales avec l'Assurance
Maladie régulièrement et qui donc
organise la médecine et ils ont commis
ils sont dans la cogestion d'un système
qui aujourd'hui aboutit à des
dysfonctionnements et à des pénuries de
force médicale sur le territoire et donc
ils doivent comprendre qu'aujourd'hui ce
temps là est terminé et qui doivent
participer à
aller en général l'exercice
4e année elle va devenir obligatoire à
terme quatrième année obligatoire
pendant quelques années et puis on verra
les résultats que ça donne mais il y a
une autre mesure qui est qui est aussi
l'interdiction de de l'intérim médical
pour les nouveaux praticiens les
nouveaux médecins c'est-à-dire l'intérim
d'aujourd'hui l'hôpital ne peut pas
faire 100e aucune organisation qu'une
entreprise ne peut travailler sans
intérêt mais néanmoins l'hôpital doit
réussir à fonctionner avec moins
d'intérim parce que l'intérim n'est pas
un système permanent dans lequel on peut
s'installer c'est sûr que c'est
attractif quand vous êtes médecin et que
vous gagnez 2000 euros par jour c'est à
dire en gros quasiment le tiers de votre
salaire en une journée vous avez plutôt
envie de vous mettre dans la terrible
que de rester praticien salarié mais
néanmoins vous déstabilisez l'hôpital et
c'est sans doute pas bon ni aussi pour
la qualité de la prise en charge d'avoir
des médecins qui vont qui viennent ou
des paramédicaux qui vont qui viennent
dans les services donc il faut
effectivement lutter contre l'intérim et
permettre aux jeunes qui s'engagent et
bien de le faire dans la dans des
équipes je veux dire permanentes ou en
permanence alors autre sujet santé parce
que on rappelle vous avez été président
de la Fédération hospitalière de France
mais il y a plus de 4300 litres
d'hospitalisation complète qui ont été
fermées l'an passé et au total entre
2016 et 2021 il y a plus de 21000 lits
qui ont été supprimés qu'est-ce qu'on
doit dire aux Français autour de ça
comment on le justifie volonté comptable
volonté de réorganisation alors il y a
différents phénomènes mais il faut aussi
dire que parallèlement on a beaucoup
augmenté le nombre de places en Gédé en
en ambulatoire c'est à dire pour
accueillir les patients le matin et
repartent le soir parce que la médecine
a évolué et qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'opérations permettent que vous rentrez
chez vous le soir même du jour de
l'intervention ou pour des traitements
lourds là où vous gardez pour des
chimiothé parfois deux jours là on vous
libère des soirs même on a beaucoup
augmenté aussi les places en
hospitalisation à domicile c'est une
autre manière de faire et qu'aujourd'hui
il faut arrêter d'être fasciné par le
nombre de lits à l'hôpital comme si on
on était obligé de garder les gens du
propriétaire
ça explique une partie du sujet l'autre
partie du sujet c'est qu'effectivement
il y a beaucoup de livres lesquels c'est
parce que il y a pas de soignants à
mettre au pied du lit et donc quand il y
a pas de soignant on mettra pas être du
lit on prend pas de risque on ferme les
lits et on ferme les chambres et on
attend que de pouvoir recruter il y a
aujourd'hui je le redis 30% de médecins
qui manque dans les services
hospitaliers il y a entre 10 et 15% on
dit à peu près de d'infirmiers
infirmières qui manque dans les services
hospitaliers inévitablement ça a des
répercussions sur la voilure que l'on
est capable très clairement monsieur
valtry en capacité aujourd'hui de
réabsorber le choc d'une nouvelle
pandémie du type de covid
la réponse est oui mais à un coût qui
serait très compliqué la réponse est oui
parce que parce que
pour les soignants parce que pour les
patients pour les patients la réponse
est oui il serait pris en charge mais
effectivement au prix d'une fatigue sans
doute encore plus forte au prix d'une
usure et surtout dans une difficulté
plus grande parce que malheureusement
l'hôpital va plus mal après le covid
qu'il n'était avant et avant il était
déjà malade
on a vu un autre sujet apparaître alors
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau mais les
cyberattaques se multiplient sur les
établissements de santé alors on a dit
les hôpitaux sont mal protégés les
protégeons de plus en plus un guide
gouvernement mais ce qu'on va
suffisamment loin dans cette protection
et ce qu'il faut pas que l'État vienne
en aide aux établissements alors l'état
viandes il y a eu il y a eu un premier
plan qui a été annoncé d'accompagnement
il y a quelques mois il y en a eu un
deuxième après l'attaque de
Corbeil-Essonnes ou l'État a remis
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
pour accompagner les établissements à se
sécuriser on sait bien qu'à ce jeu là de
toute façon c'est le jeu du chat et la
souris on n'est jamais suffisamment
protégé il n'y a pas une grande
institution depuis la CIA où je sais pas
quel un grand institution américaine qui
n'échappe aussi berattaque on sait bien
que c'est un des investissements
permanents ce qui est vrai c'est que
dans les hôpitaux peut mieux faire et
c'est urgent parce que un hôpital qui
est hacké ou qui attaqué comme comme on
l'a eu ces derniers mois sa déstabilise
complètement les établissements
l'hôpital de Pau a mis des mois et des
mois à refaire complètement son système
informatique avec tout ce que ça veut
dire derrière comme difficulté qui
s'ajoutent aux difficultés du quotidien
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
évidemment c'est déstabilisant aussi
pour la qualité de l'offre de soins
d'importance sur laquelle vous planchez
c'est la réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui consiste à ajuster les
indemnisations des chômeurs en fonction
de la vitalité du marché du travail
c'est une réforme qui va passer là aussi
en tout cas qui va te présenter dans un
social explosif est-ce que vous là vous
comptez sur les républicains pour vous
aider à faire passer cette réforme
écoutez on a travaillé pendant trois
jours en commission des affaires
sociales à l'Assemblée sur ce texte on a
terminé hier franchement j'ai
l'impression que il y a aujourd'hui non
pas évidemment consensus mais en tous
les cas il y aura une majorité je pense
sur ce texte
oui sans doute parce que il y a des
amendements qui ont été acceptés et et
plutôt positif et je pense notamment sur
la valorisation le dispositif de la VL
la valorisation des acquises expériences
qui renforcée aussi dans ce projet loi
c'est indispo c'est aussi dans ce texte
là que sa figure et pour le coup c'est
un acquis c'est une vraie avancée de
pouvoir demain permettre à plus de
français par la VAE de pouvoir obtenir
des diplômes et rentrer dans des
parcours qualifiants et ça c'est positif
et notamment c'est des amendements LR
qui ont permis de bonifier ce cette
assurance chômage qui serait selon un
rythme contrastique c'est le terme qui
est employé
quand est-ce qu'on en sera un petit peu
plus c'est le modèle canadien qui va
être qui va être copié en fait ce texte
il permet surtout aux partenaires
sociaux à partir du de moment où il y
avait de voté de pouvoir discuter des
règles et de la nouvelle génération de
la convention qui va organiser
énormément c'est une ligne de crête qui
est difficile parce qu'on a un système
qui effectivement est géré par les
partenaires sociaux le partenaire
sociaux qui dont on sait qu'il ne
s'accorderont pas sur ce projet mais on
verra là encore mais en tous les cas le
gouvernement permet d'abord que le faute
système fonctionne donc couvre les
prochains mois pour que les discussion
se fasse entre les partenaires sociaux
et selon des règles qui précisément sont
ils doivent entre déterminer voilà donc
je vais pas rentrer dans le trop d'état
parce que je ne le sais pas ce que sera
la discussion et effectivement si à
l'arrivée des partenaires sociaux ne
s'entendent pas comme vous le dites le
gouvernement prendra ses responsabilités
comme il l'a fait en en 2020 on
constatant effectivement l'échec des
discussions alors vous avez peut-être vu
notre garde des sceaux Eric
Dupond-Moretti qui est interrogé sur les
affaires quatre nains c'est l'affaire
Julien Bayou euh de violences sexistes
et sexuelles alerter sur une société de
délation je le cite en construction et
appeler à siffler la fin de la
récréation est-ce qu'il a raison de de
pointer du doigt cette gestion moi je
pense que j'ai trouvé son intervention
très à propos oui je trouve qu'il a
raison de de dire ça part mal tout ça
mal dire aujourd'hui on voit des
accusations sur des plateaux de
télévision comme celle contre Julien
Bayou dont on ne personne a bien compris
ce qui avait derrière si elles étaient
fondées ou pas l'auteur a même dit ben
je dis ça mais en même temps je sais
qu'il y a rien de pédalement
répréhensible dans ce que j'évoque enfin
voilà madame Rousseau voilà donc ces
méthodes là
voilà on on a connu et on voit encore
dans certains pays on a connu les
premiers les process staliniens dans les
années 50 ou tout d'un coup des gens
étaient accusés comme ça je sais pas
mais il faut éviter ça c'est à dire
effectivement cette justice que l'on
rend soi-même
au nom d'une morale dont voilà et selon
des des en plus des des comment dire des
dispositifs internes aux parties qu'on
comprend pas très bien il y a des voilà
tout ça est confus tout ça et et
nauséabond et il y a une justice en
France et si il y a des faits qui
relèvent du pénal et il y a l'article 40
il faut les dénoncer mais j'ai un
pénalement il faut aller devant le
procure de la République il faut porter
plainte si on a connaissance de faits
qui sont pénalement
justice soi-même devant
se sont créés au sein des parties c'est
aussi que la réponse de la justice était
insuffisante est-ce que vous-même au
sein de du d'horizon par exemple est-ce
que vous pouvez imaginer de mettre en
place une cellule d'écoute on peut pas
dire ça on peut pas dire la justice par
insuffisante je crée alors ça veut dire
on fait des ministres de quartier on
range la justice soi-même on s'arme tous
parce que on trouve que la police est
pas assez efficace parce que voilà non à
ce jeu là le glissement vous voyez le
glissement il est il est il est rapide
donc non il y a une justice il y a la
possibilité d'alerter la justice si on
est on a de soi-même de faits qui sont
délits et à partir de là il faut rentrer
dans les procédures si au moins la
procédure que l'on entend ne va pas au
bout il y a toujours manière de dire je
comprends pas pourquoi avoir après avoir
dénoncé tel ou telle fait la justice ne
réagit pas mais voyez c'est pas du tout
la méthode que vous êtes contre même ces
cellules d'écoute
je suis super contre les cellules
d'écoute bien sûr que non je suis contre
la manière dont aujourd'hui certains
agissent c'est à dire en en jetant comme
ça
et nous effectivement en pâture sans
derrière que les choses soient
clairement dit
le maire de Reims que vous connaissez
bien en au robinet qui vous a succédé
aussi à la tête de la Fédération
Hospitalière France a souhaité dans un
entretien au JDD qu'Edouard Philippe
s'affirme rapidement comme un candidat
pour 2027 est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui oui mais enfin je crois qu'il y
a pas tellement de secrets enfin c'est
il doit s'affirmer mais affirmer
c'est-à-dire ben quand on crée un parti
politique quand on veut faire vivre le
centre droit quand on veut réérer
une femme réunir des élus dans une
famille politique quand on veut
développer à un corpus d'idées structuré
quand on veut incarner l'aile le droit
de la majorité présidentielle si bien et
qu'on veut et qu'on se met dans la
perspective de penser la France
2030-2050 c'est bien je veux dire c'est
comme dirait d'office c'est pas pour
beurrer les tartines
c'est pour se mettre dans une dynamique
politique et cette dynamique politique
la mènera sans doute le moment venu à
être présent à différentes élections
comme on l'a été comment l'a été au
législative et comment on sera aussi
natariale
merci beaucoup
qui a été mis en liquidation judiciaire
en effet dans le Nord notamment et 2600
licenciements partout en France merci
beaucoup Julien d'avoir
[Musique]